did you have any concerns about turning
your book into a TV series because I
don't know are you ever afraid they'll
change it or alter like how you did it
you know yeah oh they're always going to
change it and they should I mean it
needs to be the best TV show it can be
yeah uh I wasn't really worried about
that I I knew that I had chosen the
right people as partners and I knew they
were going to do a good job but yeah no
one's ever heard of Reese Witherspoon's
yeah well I really took a chance on her
yeah but uh but the thing that all of us
like I remember having a very early
meeting and it was like look we're gonna
find this band we're gonna figure it out
we're gonna figure out the music
um I don't it's going to be really hard
to find Daisy Jones that was the thing
it was gonna be really hard to find
Daisy Jones and it was like how are you
gonna find someone who's that
charismatic how are you going to find
someone who's that magnetic how are you
going to find someone who can be so you
know
complicated but at the same time draw
everyone to her and uh and then they
start casting I think it was like maybe
two weeks later I get an email there's
no
body of the email it's just a subject
line and it just says Riley Keough is
Daisy Jones question mark and I just
wrote back I mean there was an expletive
in what I said so I'll just paraphrase
thank you which was like absolutely yes
we have to do it and and from that
moment on everyone just felt like the
bar was so high with Riley being cast
that everyone else had to be that good
and I thought at some point they were
going to drop the ball on that but they
they really didn't and it started with
you
[Music]
[Applause]
songs or your babies right these
characters so I can imagine that's hard
to be like who's gonna not screw this up
it's like yeah yeah well and you do you
you come to care about them so much and
I could tell you everything that Daisy
would do or wouldn't do or what Billy
would do or wouldn't do and you want to
make sure one of the people who are
adapting it understand those things but
then also the people who are playing it
see the same thing in it that you see in
it and I just feel really I
like feel like it's pinched myself
dreaming that this cast is not only that
all of you are so right for the roles
that you're playing but also it's just
so clear and it was clear from band camp
and I feel like it's even clearer now
like you guys just like each other and
you get along you have a chemistry that
like you know which is kind of funny
though because
two of the characters don't get along
and then right well you know they
certainly have done competing interests
yeah but um but it's interesting yeah
yeah right yeah yeah
it happens chemistry is I think what
what makes a TV show a lot of times yeah
and like watching them is just in the
final product chemistry yeah that's
everything I agree well Riley which part
of Daisy did you connect with most is
there anything
yeah I think that one of the biggest
things that I connected with was the
challenges she sort of faced as a female
artist being taken seriously
um that was the big one for me and
having all these sort of people let her
down or um
yeah you know just that sort of struggle
which I'm sure in the 70s would have
been even more Amplified from drugs and
alcohol
and just having experienced that kind of
thing myself as a female artist yeah um
you know everybody's a little bit flawed
and everybody you know messes up but I
think ultimately she did such a good job
at at portraying all of these really
complicated men and women
um and their relationships with each
other and it was just um I think that's
important that that's real right because
you're portraying like in essence like a
real band like a real and if you're
first of all playing an artist we are
complicated like it's like you know I'm
saying there are a lot of layers to that
onion and I think that's going to be
more fun to play anyway right like to
act like to play Someone complicated
that could be really endearing and
Charming at one moment but then just
totally like off their rocker the next
like wait a minute what's happening it's
so much more fun yeah you know I mean I
think we can all speak for that and I
think that all the women on the show are
so you know complicated complicated and
have so many moments of you know
opportunities to you know as a performer
explore these these nuances and I think
that Taylor did such a wonderful job at
facilitating us with that yeah
absolutely well everybody Daisy Jones
and the six is now on Prime video the
book is available now as well wherever
you get your books
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]